One of the hardest things for a human to comprehend
is the idea of an end.
The idea of our existence ending and not having
the slightest definitive clue as to where
it may or may not go.
How we can fall in love with life and all
the things within it.
How we can feel so strongly about our passions
and careers.
And how we can analyze, appreciate, and mend
the features of our identity, all for it just
to end and dissolve into the ether.
Like all living organisms, as soon as we are
born, we begin our journey towards death.
We travel through life with our finite timeline
hovering over us, forced to live with the
increasing pressure of only having so much
time to decide what to do with time itself.
When we are young, we don’t think or worry
about this so much.
Our consciousness is not yet developed enough
to consider the concept of life and death.
But as we get older and step more and more
into our consciousness, we begin to grasp
the shortness and complexity of life as we
realize that our parents and teachers no longer
have all the answers to our increasingly critical
questions of life.
And interestingly, simultaneous to our developing
realization of this, our life becomes filled
with increasing amounts of work and responsibility.
As a child, we go from hanging around at home,
to having to go to school.
And as we progress through school, each grade
becomes slightly harder and more time consuming
than the previous.
Then we go from high school to college or
a career and then hopefully to success, as
we might define it, each stage requiring more
and more of our time and energy.
It appears that as we become closer and more
aware of life’s approaching end, life requires
more and more from us.
But why is it that we are willing to invest
increasing amounts of time and energy into
a life that we are getting closer and closer
to losing?
Why work our life away in pursuit of goals
and achievements for them to most likely just
dissolve away with us when we die.
The reason is simple.
We strive for purpose, achievement, and wealth,
beyond just our survival needs, because it
distracts us from thinking about this very
idea of our mortality in a healthy and sustainable
way.
What’s worse than to live and work towards
something that doesn’t ultimately matter
to the universe, is to live a life having
done nothing but sit with fear and sadness.
To waste the experience on inactivity.
If we do not work towards goals and dreams,
we will have nothing to focus on and all of
our unutilized time and energy will divert
towards destructive habits in an attempt to
occupy our mind away from thinking about death
and futility.
Purpose and success is arguably nothing more
than a human construct designed to distract
us from the fact that we are only conscious
enough to create and achieve, but not conscious
enough to understand the point of any of it.
To acquire true purpose and success in life
is not necessarily to achieve wealth, fame,
or status, but to feel the passion and vitality
that comes from working towards goals and
dreams.
To be happily distracted away from worrying
about life’s complexity and shortness.
In life, we play video games, board games,
sports games etc. not because they go on forever,
but because they are fun and engage our capacity
to feel human.
We play them because they help us forget about
the reality of life’s impermanence.
And because we need the feeling of having
some participation in the collective happenings
around us in order to feel happy and alive.
And the game of life itself is no different.
By nature, we are all competitive beings.
And to not work, contribute, and feel involved
is to feel unimportant and lesser than our
fellow humans.
And there are few things that kill a soul
quicker than the feeling of inferiority and
insignificance.
Even more so than the realization of the absurdity
of the game itself.
Ultimately we are left with two choices in
life.
Play and enjoy the game as best we can, or
stay on the sidelines and complain about
the rules.